but i was talking to a friend of mine
who said i got hit up
this morning what's the proud boys tim
and i said uh
they're a western chauvinist group um
are they racist and i was like
uh there's been some people in but i
think the organization as a whole what
they stand for
is absolutely not like uh their their
leader is a black cuban guy so i don't
think that's you know
of course the media will say it but
anyway the point is for somebody to
message me saying i don't know what that
means
right away i'm like that part of the
debate was completely meaningless
to most people yeah they're gonna be
like i don't know what a proud boy is
what is that it's like it's like it's
like an lb lgbt thing or something no
for real
because that was like one of the jokes
the left was doing yeah like claiming
you know that like the proud boys and
they made like a rainbow website or
whatever
so i think as if that's a bad thing
right right they thought the proud boys
would be offended by it right
it was great i don't think you know
anything about these guys yeah you know
so there was a video that was going
around
just made me think of old gavin class
yeah i know
i can't believe some of the things that
guy would do on camera man right so look
you know i was talking to a friend of
mine earlier who was like posting and
talking about
how donald trump is calling for his
right-wing militias to come and get
ready and i was like listen
the proud boys are a lot of things white
supremacist is not one of them
you can criticize them for a lot but
they're not white supremacists that's
like that's ridiculous it does come from
gavin's
inception i think do you see the vic
burger uh rogan
gavin mcginnis clip that you did today i
think came out this morning what is it
it was a rogan said you know gavin
mcginnis is mostly fun fun
guy and then vic burger was like oh glad
he said that and then all these clips of
you haven't been like you find someone
choke him by the throat and choke
well he was saying a lot no it was just
clip after clip after some of those
some of those clips are gavin talking
about dogs that's inc oh are you kidding
me yes
specific no you're not kidding one of
the uh like up so
one of the clips you know what fact
check me on this one for sure but but
apparently
uh because i didn't i don't watch
gavin's show when he was talking about
choking uh a bee he was literally
talking about pulling a choke chain on a
dog that was disobeying you
okay so look dude there are a lot of
people
that will take everything out of context
manipulate cut it and they just run with
it and it works
it works so that's a good point sorry
that's a good point though they take
everything out of context they run a
clip they
they're gonna say whatever they want so
one of the things that people vote one
of the reasons people vote for trump is
because they want him to be a fighter
they want him to attack the
establishment they want him to attack
the media
so what we witnessed was trump's
manifestation
of that energy right he was just doing
it
whether what he said was precise or had
the right answer
the energy was there right he was
fighting biden he was
fighting the moderator and he was taking
control
which is what every single trump voter
wanted
when they pulled that you know in the
election booth for trump was for him to
go in
take on these guys the twin pillars of
the democrat well actually
the political establishment in general
and the media
and attack them but but the the question
i have is
there's a lot of people who didn't vote
in 2016
who now are probably going to vote
because they're being activated by
all this all the smear pieces on all the
you know all the media being like
at the end of the world you have to go
vote you know and all the stuff are they
being activated by that are they being
activated by waking up one day and
finding out that their third graders are
being taught to hate their whiteness and
putting forth in the struggle sessions
i don't think they know that i i think
dude maybe it's just because of the
business i'm in and the things that i
write about but i'm being contacted by
parents all over the country yeah maybe
who are saying that they
are appalled at what's happening in
their schools with critical race theory
yeah but that's activating people but
are they going to like trump couldn't
even answer what critical race theory
was i tweeted about that
it was clear that not none of the three
guys on the stage
knew really what critical race theory
was yep just the way they talked about
it
and chris wallace you know what this was
the most infuriating thing to me
the dude didn't even bother google
searching what it was
before he presented to two presidential
candidates
he's the one who picked these things
talk about
inept chris wallace should be not never
look man he's a nice guy boomer he's a
nice guy get him out of there
get him out because he could have at
least done a simple he could have gone
to wikipedia
and been like here's critical race
theory instead what he just
paired it up garbage talking points he
got from like some click bait activist
blog didn't even call it critical race
theory did he
call it racial sense that means he
didn't even know what trump's policy was
yeah he had no idea that was pathetic
talk about pathetic
so trump clearly was he was patterning
when he was like oh it's bad it's racist
or whatever it's you know trump should
have had a better answer
for what it was but you know what he did
ban it
and like that's good but let me tell you
something
i i i talk to my progressive friends you
know
as much as like the lefties like to say
tim's anecdotes don't count i don't care
whatever they're making i'm gonna tell
them anyway
and my friend was was telling me that
she's like all in for biden
like all in for biden trump is bad and
the conversation was interesting because
i'm not
i'm not sure you know i think she'll
probably still vote for biden
but she was saying that trump is the
reason for canceled culture no
that and i'm like that's right exactly
of course not yeah but uh
the gist of the conversation that that i
took away from it was
trump's attitude is normalizing and
inflaming
all of this ridiculous behavior and i
said trump is a symptom
not the cause of the only reason trump's
here is because this was bubbling up and
people finally snapped
and they were like whatever man send in
the bull and so that trump just storms
through and he's ripping things apart
you know he's like just trampling around
and i don't mean that to say that he's
destroying the system no he's like the
establishment is getting trampled all
over
but it was interesting to me that my
friend was like when we were talking
politics
she got really into how she was sick of
cancer culture and how it's like
everywhere
and how people can't even talk anymore
and i was like then why would you
support joe biden
well because trump just like won't shut
up he won't shut up and i'm like
that's how you fight that's how you
fight cancel culture that's how you
fight political correctness by not
shutting up and i've heard people
criticize
saying trump isn't the right guy to
fight critical race theory
and i'm like get out of here first of
all that's why i voted for him that's
what the whole book is about pretty much
except for economics and war and some
other things
but about fighting the canceled culture
of woke political correctness etc
radical feminism all of that and what i
said in a tweet once was
you know he may not be no he is the man
for the fight because he is the man
fighting
like who else is doing it well we i i
think we
i think we need better i'm not saying
trump is
like bad at the fight i'm saying
there will come someone after trump yes
who will be
faster stronger better and right now
trump is the avatar of that energy
like all of that all of that anger over
unjust systems the escalation of leftist
identitarianism
the the the crony trade policies
it formed this energy and it incarnated
itself in in donald trump
and so he's just like this it's almost
like
i don't know if you get the reference
you get do you watch dragon ball z do
you know anything about it
the very famous goku like he summons all
of the energy from people all over the
earth
and then he throws it at the bad guy and
crushes him that's trump trump is that
energy being like just
thrown at the establishment so i do
think there will come a time whether no
matter what happens
in this election where there will be a
very trumpian moderate right-leaning
conservative type
but who is faster smoother
you know more much more charismatic
because this
this personality is probably going to
bubble up there's going to be like a pop
there's going to be this is there's a
you know 65 million people
one of them is going to start talking
and then people are going to be like
check this person out that's our leader
that's the person who's going to step up
after trump
so i think like like i'm not saying you
know trump
uh is bad i think there will be better
though
you know let's hope otherwise what what
do we get
you know what so so i'll tell you this
in the conversation now with my friend
totally off the subject of cancel
culture stuff i just
you know she said to me i'm worried
there's way too many social issues
that we're facing trouble with if trump
wins again
and my first response was like you know
actually i think it's the other way
around
i think you know trump if he wins we're
going to get a lot of
the same you know the way america has
been and if biden wins we're going to
get leftist identitarianism
but i'll tell you this you know what if
you want to come and tell me
that you're concerned about your
comforts here in the united states
and you voted for barack obama twice
this is your penance donald trump
has signed three historic peace
agreements this is incredible
i mean all three of these agreements
recognize israel as a country
the united arab emirates and bahrain two
arabic nations recognizing and
normalizing relations
amazing trump got nominated for two
peace prizes over that then he's got uh
or i think
technically one for those then he's got
kosovo serbia which did include them
recognizing israel as well but also
normalizes relations peace
nobel peace prize nomination then he
gets the third nomination
over uh the trump doctrine of you know
pulling our troops out of the middle
east and peace
so here we finally have after how many
years 20 years a president who's like i
don't care i'm pulling the troops out
this was a mistake
is it perfect no but my my point to
my friend was very simple over the past
20 years
how many civilians have been killed in
these foreign conflicts that we should
have never been involved in
how much money wasted and how many
americans live lives lost
and when obama came around you know what
i voted for him too i voted for him i'm
like here we go
hey the war was a problem what does
obama do he increased our footprint him
and biden expanded our presence in north
africa and the middle east
making everything work worse and not
work worse
and now libya following the air raids
and our involvement has brought back
slavery
and that was the obama administration
and so i'll tell you this
you do not get to come to me and say but
what about my comforts
when you voted for a guy twice i i would
i would accept you voted from the first
time
but you voted for him again in 2012 and
that means that he started more wars he
got us deeper involved
and now people are dying the first thing
that needs to happen is the people need
to stop dying that's my opinion
on this then after we we we we
stop the war we can have a conversation
about fixing things back here at home
and you know reallocating those funds
towards infrastructure maybe fixing
flint and all that stuff
but the point i'm trying to make is
right now the president we have who's
going to end this
endless war and garbage conflict and
bring about peace is donald trump
and if that means he's the person i have
to vote for to get that to get that
point
and it means you might have social issue
troubles well maybe you shouldn't have
voted for
for barack obama because you can't just
kick the can down the road
take all of the good sweet things he
whispered into your ears while he bombed
kids and civilians in foreign countries
and then finally when i say i'm putting
an end to what you voted for you go but
what about me
well what about the kids that obama blew
up okay i'm sorry
that you that like you're concerned
about your your taxes
you know or your social programs like i
really am i want to make sure that
people have health care and all of these
things too
but if you're going to come to me and be
like here's a kid who's scarred
permanently because of like white
phosphorus and drone strikes and
hellfire missiles and here's you
you know complaining that your health
care is higher in cost this this this
month around yeah but that's from
obamacare first of all how many of these
how many of these perceived social ills
are real right and how and how many of
them are actually being suffered by
people who did vote for trump in the
first place
now funny thing when is when do they
award
the nobel peace prizes december december
i'm pretty sure isn't it december man if
only it were before the election
[Laughter]
i don't think they're not going to give
it to him dude
why not yeah why not funny guy funny guy
they nominated joe biden some some
british guy nominated joe biden that
made me laugh for what
for what i don't know oh my goodness
what does joe bite
for for uh backing up obama no no no he
he got nominated for the nobel peace
prize
for being out of politics for four years
but in the previous four years
he was blowing up kids yeah that's the
thing it's not only is trump pulling him
out
which he is joe biden was the vp that
got it in he's not just it's not like
it's not like trump or some other guy
it's trump or the dude that helped
perpetuate and hillary clinton
also you know you know what i think like
fans might disdain for the democratic
party
being someone who's like pretty liberal
on policy issues
is that i remember growing up having all
of these people when i was like a
teenager and and you know getting older
and coming into politics
running around me saying like aren't you
gonna fight against george w bush's war
it was wrong and i see the music videos
like system of a down and they're like
everyone's protesting
and i saw and i said this is bs the
media lied to us there were no weapons
of mass destruction it was a scam
and now we're over there in in some
other country for
for who knows why people are dying our
people are dying we're wasting money
and i got mad and so then barack obama
comes around and i'm like i don't know
man and my friends are all like dude
look at this here's a video of obama
saying we're going to get our troops out
of the middle east and i'm like
wow we got to do it we have to because
everybody was
was screaming in my ears for these past
eight years
or you know six seven years so i voted
for him and then like within two weeks
obama signed off on a drone strike blow
up a village killing women and children
and i was like who who were these people
so then i immediately go to these people
again and i'm like hey remember that
thing you were telling me about
about ending the war and then they're
like oh our guy won later and they left
and all the activism stopped all there
was still some anti-war activists they
still exist
they're they're i think i i i respect
them greatly a lot of the anti-war left
they're still in a great job and many of
them
are very progressive but all of a sudden
this big wave of people screaming and
waving signs gone
just gone just not there anymore 2012
comes around and i'm like
you you used me you lied to me
you dangled corpses of children in front
of my face and then told me that's why i
had to vote for your guy
and i did it and then you turned your
back on me i cannot stand these people
and now we're sitting here looking at it
again and donald trump is pulling the
troops out he's trying to and this both
democrats and republicans are trying to
stop him
and he's got these historic peace
agreements and i'm like there finally
and
then i get more progressives being like
but what about my social issues
okay i'll tell you what i'm gonna how
about you come with me
i will literally fly you to yemen and
we'll go to the cafe that was blown up
by barack obama
and after you look at it and talk to the
families about their families dying
then we'll come back and figure out
what's more important to you
it was it was me being brought up by con
artists
who were trying to manipulate a young
voter into supporting their guy and they
wanted war and they care they cared for
nothing but
more war more incursion more bs i will
say
if obama lost in 2008 it would have been
john mccain i think
you're right and he would have got us
into iran he would have been way worse
so obama was the least bad in that
situation as horrible as he was
you are complete you are completely
correct oh yeah yeah you were completely
correct mccain was
was way worse and psychotic and that's
why this maga movement
is different it's different than the
democrats it's different than the gop
because that was one of the main things
that people were talking about and if
you remember at time of the election
last time
it was syria right syria was the big
thing and the dividing line and this is
a whole chapter in my book democrat to
deplorable on amazon go get it
is was when hillary clinton was like
there's going to be a no-fly zone
we're going to bomb these people blah
blah blah and trump was like no
no it's going to be world war iii it's
going to be war with russia no more war
and then they
that's where that's where the rush of
things i do want to clarify too though
ian because you're correct mitt romney
and mccain were bad mccain would have
been the worst
my issue was with the activists who told
me i was standing side by side with them
to end the war
and as soon as they won they left and
walked away you know i had a dream
earlier today uh that i was talking to
jimmy kimmel
and he was doing a show and he was
telling everyone
trump is bad it's we he has to change
this he has to change this and i said no
i have to change it we have to change it
it's up to me
and then it was like a pause and he said
i have to change it and then
everyone in the room started saying i
have to change it and then
the jimmy's show that he was doing
stopped it stopped because
the whole yelling of trump thing wasn't
selling anymore he no longer had a show
so he just sat down he was like i've got
to be the one and i said i'm sorry that
taking responsibility is it doesn't sell
your product and he said
it's okay that moment of taking
responsibility will go viral
and then publicize the rest of my work
going forward
interesting a dream about jimmy kimmel
yeah that would that would never happen
because kimmel would just start laughing
and he'd be like but trump is bad
i watched his appeal last night it was
disgusting the
the the garbage word vomit coming out of
the mouths of all of the late-night
comedians where they might as well just
be all
saying rabble rabble rebel it's the same
recycled garbage they're not talking
anything of substance
they're not saying anything that matters
it is just like hey i'm just like you i
don't like trump hey we don't like trump
either
we got no reason to not like trump and
then they say things like did you see
donald trump wouldn't disavow white
supremacy
any any honest person who watched that
did not walk away with that
it's it's what they're hoping for is low
information voters
and low information culture war
belligerence to be like well there's
something be mad about i guess
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live monday through friday at 8pm so
come back to check us out when we go
live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you